und was ist jetzt endlich daheim man hat
gesehen was kann ich dafür dass mit
dieser doch länger gedauert eur kaufen
doch selber einkaufen sind doch deine
eltern die zum abendessen kommen
überlegt du dir doch was hier zum
schmorbraten machen ich bin doch nicht
deine moment habt ihr vielleicht wirst
[Musik]
entschuldigung sind sie hierfür die
kartoffeln zuständig
kartoffeln von mir aus wie viel kostet
das kilo um kilo kartoffeln acht euro 8
euro und er sei nicht gerade ein
schnäppchen aber okay wenn sie frisch
sind und höhere frisch seien zufrieden
so viel los du nur geguckt was sind sie
denn auch sauber diese kartoffeln ich
will ja nicht dass sie mir mein cabrio
vertreten neben zahnbürste werden die
ganz wichtig und oregano inseln im
fischhaus die folie bock
5 in wunderbar
5km passen am besten geht jetzt in die
zweite reihe weiter warner und noch
kommst du wieder vorbei zu bewegen
[Musik]
gut
mein gott sie wollen sind hier jetzt
habe ich auch noch wieder der letzte
bauer dass ich ihr kartoffeln
wahnsinn
du kannst jetzt mit denen die stiegl
schränke auf und trug ihn nur 6 prozent
wirklich auf der spur
[Musik]
[Applaus]